anything else anybody wants to talk
about before right yeah you mean in the
Buddhist sense of in life well this sort
of goes to this question which we've
talked about in other for a long other
avenues of approach which is the
question do psychedelics have anything
to do with so called spirituality
enlightenment well there are different
notions of what enlightenment is first
of all I mean there's a soft version a
kind of Protestant version where people
say well enlightenment is something
which comes and goes from each of us
many times a day if we could but cling
to it we would know it and it is you
know our absent friend weaving in and
out of ordinary experience that's the
soft version of enlightenment but then
you know there's a hard version of
enlightenment which says if a single
sentient being attains enlightenment for
a single nanosecond anywhere in the
kilee of Kazem of eternity then all
sentient beings will instantly be sucked
into the presence of the parinirvana and
the illusion of space and time will
collapse and the tathagata will be
eminent and so forth and so on
I sort of like the hard version because
makes it easier to know when you're in
the presence of it it was I don't know I
mean this is an interesting question oh
you know I suppose them I mean they do
an Orthodox Buddhist of the hardcore
sort I think they're fairly contemptuous
of psychedelic owes and what they would
lay on us is that we are obsessed with
sang saara that our love of the 10,000
things will forever stand between us and
union with
the undescribable unutterable Platini
anon entity outside of all realms of
description and anticipation and so
forth and so on probably true it's just
that you know buying into that that
thing exists at all is a major step and
you know I'm willing to play the Pied
Piper there I'm interested in the 10,000
things I mean what thrills me are
museums full of butterflies and
libraries full of books and galleries
full of paintings and parties full of
women and just the multiplicity of
things and that's what psychedelics seem
to celebrate on the other hand it's very
hard to be a psychedelic person I think
and not participate in one of the
central tenants of both Buddhism and
Hinduism which is the primacy of mind
mind only the dogma that you know all
manifestation is somehow a product of
the ratiocination of mine that's a
pretty pretty Buddhist point of view I
think you can secure I think you can
make progress spiritually with
psychedelics but not necessarily where
psychedelics and the spiritual
marketplace find themselves
shoulder-to-shoulder I think is when you
run up against the adherence of
Shaivite yoga's of various sorts where
there is definitely a stress on
visionary phenomena internal
transformation of body states magical
powers so forth and so on and you know
there's quite a feeling of
competitiveness I studied some of those
yoga's I certainly don't claim to be an
expert my conclusions about Indian
spirituality were largely unhappy ones I
mean it seemed to me that the the shell
of something was there but that it had
been for millennia counterfeited and
adulterated and manipulated and that it
was that I can't imagine a longer path
to spiritual breakthrough than the path
that leads through the ashrams and and
so forth of Mother India
the spiritual unfoldment is an act of
imagination there may be other things
that are acts of imagination that aren't
like that I mean like the designing of a
building or the managing of a company
they also might profit from psychedelics
but for sure I think if you have
spiritual intent as a precondition
psychedelic use is just going to be very
important to you all the spiritual
methods seem to work in the presence of
psychedelics the methods which in my
experience largely don't work any other
time for example Yantra mantra chanting
visualization
[Music]
conjuration in some cases all of these
things which are very resistant to
functioning an ordinary mental space
work like a charm just over the line so
I imagine you know that why our
religions are so pale and tepid and
unsatisfying is we're like sitting
around in fine automobiles but nobody
bothered to fill the gas tank and so you
know we play we play the radio and we
turn on the windshield wipers and the
blinkers and but we don't go anywhere
and it's because what you need is
spiritual technique shamanic technique
religious practice in the presence of a
boundary dissolving pharmacological fuel
and then it really happens and if you
have the pharmacological fuel but not
the spiritual intent then what you
become is a very is a philosopher of
some sort a Michael Tao sig I mean I'm
really interested in Michael Tao Stieg
I've never met the guy but when you read
his book on ayahuasca it's wonderful
there's a that's what makes horse races
you see but I'm sure we would agree
whether we think the book is awful or
wonderful that there is not a spiritual
bone in this man's body not an atom of
spirituality and yet he's taken as much
ayahuasca as I or spero or anybody here
under the right conditions with the real
people and so then seeing what does it
do to that kind of mind a mind without
spiritual intent is is fascinating
in any case I think you can't catalyze
your imagination without becoming an
exceptional person you may become an
exceptional bore you may become
exceptionally overbearing or exceptional
at designing jet skis but because it
catalyzes the imagination it propels you
forth out of the ordinary
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]